[Music]
pristine Ford appears before the Senate
tomorrow as expected she won't simply be
speaking to members of the Judiciary
Committee she will also speak with
Arizona sex crimes prosecutor Rachel
Mitchell who's been tapped to ask
questions as an outside counsel what
sort of person is Rachel Mitchell what
does she do and what sort of prosecutor
has she been bill Montgomery will know
the answer he's a Maricopa County
Attorney and he is Rachel Mitchell's
boss he joins us tonight thanks very
much for coming on I appreciate it oh
you're very welcome Tucker so just to
clarify something the Washington Post
one of his colonists sent out a tweet
today saying of Republicans in Congress
describing this quote clueless old white
guys pick someone from Sheriff Joe
Arpaio's operation is is she from
Sheriff Joe Arpaio's operation no Tucker
she's not she's a deputy county attorney
which means she works for the Maricopa
County Attorney's Office sheriff's
deputies and detention officers worked
for Sheriff's thanks for clarifying that
what will she be doing tomorrow with
Christine for the tensest hearing well
if the hearing does go forward my
understanding is that she will assist
the Judiciary Committee and trying to
obtain information and get to the ground
truth of whatever allegations have been
made and cover the scope of those during
the hearing exactly how she's going to
do that I've left her alone as I do with
my prosecutors when they're about ready
to go into trial and she'll be
developing that line of questioning
based upon her training background and
experience and whatever specific
guidance she might get from the
Committee on areas of inquiry they
really want her to cover so what's her
posture what her assumptions going into
this when she speaks to someone who has
alleged a crime a felony against
somebody else who says she's a victim is
the assumption from the prosecutor that
she's telling the truth that she's not
or is it neutral
well it's neutral you know what Rachel
will do is go in and start by listening
and listen to what the allegations are
listen to what people are saying
now she certainly has a victim-centered
focus as a prosecutor but that doesn't
mean you can't accept as ground truth
everything that said it's really
important for prosecutors and something
she's been doing for about 25 years to
listen to all the facts assess what can
be proven what can be corroborated what
needs corroboration and the
conduct an overall review of the
information that she's got in order to
make a decision now ordinarily for us as
prosecutors that decision is whether or
not we should charge somebody with a
crime seek an indictment and prosecute
that's not the scenario we have here but
that basic approach to getting
information and trying to assess
credibility and what tied-up of
corroboration there might be that skill
set is equally applicable I've noticed
watching this story unfold that almost
everybody on the periphery of it has
been sucked in and damaged but cab knows
childhood friend mark judge most people
never heard of him is now the center of
in very intense criticism from the left
just because he's been named he hasn't
said anything is do you think she's
ready for that I mean she could see her
own character assassinated if she asked
questions that Democrats don't like well
unfortunately Tucker that's not new for
prosecutors so we get accused of things
every single day back here in her home
jurisdiction those who have litigated
against Rachel those who've worked with
her worked for her or who've had the
privilege of supervising her know what
her reputation is and it's based upon
her performance her actions and how she
treats other people and nothing that
happens in the hearing tomorrow will be
able to affect that she'd be able to
come back to her job hope she comes back
to her job she'll be able to come back
to her job and pick up where she left
off and she's very well-grounded
professional fair and objective and once
she's done with this she'll be able to
leave it behind that was a task that she
was called upon to do she'll perform it
and then it'll be done and just like
prosecutors have to move from one case
to the next and particularly in this
area where her background is in in sex
crimes you you've got to be able to deal
with the case work with a victim seek
justice from the accused and then go to
your next case yeah that's the right no
one's seeking justice right now so I'll
be glad to see her as the only person
doing that tomorrow thank you very much
he made us all feel better hearing that
oh you're very welcome Tucker thank you
Thanks